progressives may need some progressives
may need a bit of a wake-up call and I'm
not talking about the upcoming David
Pakman show coffee blend called
progressive wake-up call which I'll talk
to you more about in a few days I'm
talking about how to manage the Trump
presidency I want to give you an analogy
during one of the presidential debates
Donald Trump sort of implied or seemed
to believe that if he just appoints
anti-abortion Supreme Court justices
that roe v wade gets automatically
overturned right he was asked about that
and he said oh yeah it's gonna
automatically happen when I appoint
anti-choice Supreme Court justices and
afterwards commentators and analysts had
to explain what's obvious to a lot of
people which is things in our country
don't happen automatically right we have
a framework for things to happen just to
sort of use a crude colloquial term but
for things to happen certain actions
need to be taken roe v wade doesn't get
overturned merely because justices or a
majority of Justices become anti-choice
you need a case to make it to the
Supreme Court which the Supreme Court
agrees to here you have a process right
along the same lines I'm worried about
the attitude that some progressives are
taking that the Constitution and regular
fact-checking on the internet and by
media are going to stop Trump from doing
insane stuff during his presidency
here's an example that is a very
specific and current example we've
talked about the emoluments Clause of
the Constitution and Donald Trump's
conflicts of interest this is a clause
which says that the president cannot
receive gifts monitor of monetary value
from foreign nations I'm paraphrasing
now we've read it in specifically a few
times and we've talked about how Trump's
hotels including foreign diplomats who
have said oh when I come to DC I'll stay
in Crump's hotel because if I stay at
his Cantus competitons hotel that might
anger him and I might ingratiate myself
with him by staying at the hotel and
we've gone into significant detail about
how if Donald Trump doesn't truly
resolve these conflicts of interest by
January 20th that he would be in
violation of the Constitution we could
be 100% correct that Trump would be in
violation of the Constitution's
emoluments clause but so what that
doesn't trigger any action automatically
it does not do anything you would need
the political will
to prosecute Trump and this is going to
repent depend mostly on Republicans so I
know that there are many progressive
friends who are saying that's the the
second Trump gets in and he does a B or
C which violates de or F provision of
this or that it's over for Trump these
things don't happen automatically this
is a document in the Constitution which
is there as a framework but it doesn't
have this automatic capacity to make
things happen or punish people and it's
going to really depend on Republicans to
hold him to it and we don't know that
they're going to yes and this whole
thing's a very slow-moving process
probably not going to be initiated by
the Republicans I think Donald Trump has
just developed this hubris over the past
couple years where he's been able to get
away with whatever he wants with the
offensive comments that he's made with
the sexual assault allegations and he
was still elected president yeah so you
know I think he's going to continue he
even said that the president can't have
a conflict of interest right even just a
month ago that is almost like when what
is I can't believe I'm blanking but I
think it was Richard Nixon who famously
says if the president does it it's not
illegal right because the president did
it no matter it no matter what it is
Donald Trump is sort of parroting or or
mirroring one of the most horrific
statements that we've seen made with
regards to presidential power and
separation of powers and the law and
judicial independence in the United
States by by by Richard Nixon and it's
like the Republicans don't even care so
the message to progressives and I'm
mostly speaking to you in this
particular clip although believe me the
right-wingers are going to comment about
what I'm saying here is that the
Constitution alone is not going to
protect us from Donald Trump
additionally fact checking the
fact-checking movement has grown in size
it's grown in aggressiveness during
Trump's candidacy and and since Donald
Trump's win that's great
much corporate media much of corporate
media won't do the fact-checking it
needs to be done on the internet social
media independent media but we have to
remember that sitting back and assuming
that presenting trumpets with facts even
facts that expose unconstitutional or
bad actions by Trump it
not in and of itself going to do
anything if you look at the many
examples we have from around the world
you get these authoritarian strongman
types like Donald Trump and they will
preemptively prime people to just not
believe what you hear on the internet or
on independent media or on media
whatever media is bad at the moment and
Trump did this really well he started
telling his supporters the media lies
they're mostly bad people some of them
are good but they're mostly bad people
and then when media would say something
that went against what Trump was
parroting at rallies many of his
supporters were already ready to say no
no I believe Trump not media so again
it's going to require more than just
fact-checking and sharing memes on
Facebook we're trying to set up our Park
right we have this campaign at david
pakman.com slash donate the idea being
not only to grow the David Pakman show
further but really to create a position
called the progressive engagement
coordinator that's going to work very
proactively not only with our audience
right not only with you the listeners
and viewers but also with other
independent progressive shows to
coordinate our actions that's going to
be necessary Pat it for people who are
doing the social media activism awesome
right the more people that see whatever
it is that you're trying to communicate
through fact-checking on social media
that's great but we need to understand
that it's going to take more to stop
Donald Trump yeah you have to hope that
the truth will one day went over and I
think some of the trumpets will start to
turn away from him at some point
you think so eventually I hope you're
right I know that again it's Trump who
said it he could shoot people on Fifth
Avenue and many of most many all of his
supporters wouldn't care and we've seen
that that is very very significantly
true
Warby Parker is offering a free five day
home Tryon to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses I personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trialed comm slash TDP s I don't really
like going into glasses stores and
trying on glasses while the salespersons
of hovers over me and I like more than
30 seconds to actually figure out
whether I like the glasses so with the
Warby Parker home Tryon I was able to
pick five pairs that I liked put them on
in the comfort of my own home pick the
one I like the most and then Warby
Parker put my prescription lenses in
there for me a lot of people don't know
that the eyeglass industry is controlled
by just a few big corporations that keep
prices very high like three hundred
dollars for prescription glasses high
which is just insane Warby Parker
glasses start at $95 that's what mine
cost and for every pair of glasses sold
Warby Parker distributes a pair of
glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like check out the at home trial and
support our show by going to Warby
Parker comm slash TDP s it costs nothing